um
on the new album you got jack boy and
wyclef so talk to me because
obviously both haitians yeah why clef is
like the god though
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah shout
out to white cliff you got him talking
that [ __ ] on the album
how did you guys like how did that play
happen because that's the big thing
about me before the freestyle
okay so as soon as my instagram name
popped up hey baby he already he tapped
in locked in
like giving me free game a lot of advice
um giving me books to read like oh wow
through not giving me books like telling
me some books i should look up like
just uh a uncle in the industry you know
what i'm saying
now how me and jack boy met of course he
signed the empire of course
yeah you know family business bringing
them probably linked up and you guys
lincoln
studios like everything else and but
what artists realize you know a lot of
people in the in the industry
always say oh these rap [ __ ] is fake
it's faking the game but it's up to who
you mess well with so i mesh well with
jack
you know that's it's my that's me
personally me and him mesh well so
that's why it seems so good on track did
you make a
conscious effort to only have haitians
featured on the album or was that by
coincidence
by coincidence okay i'm going to sit
here